michel coulomb je disais beaucoup de
films à voir alors c'est une chronique
coastal parce que j'ai beaucoup de
suggestions pour le temps des fêtes
c'est l'abondance si on commence avec
quatre films d'abord le retour de mary
poppins suivi de roma vi est un homme
pressé
donc on les prend 1,1 pire à des primes
à la fin de les voir mais commençons
donc par le retour de mary poppins la
célèbre la très célèbre nounou anglaise
revient après 54 ans d'absence
en fait ce serait passé wenjun c'est le
grand classé oui un des plus grands
succès du cinéma américain qui se savait
pas pris une ride ce féminin n'ont
aucunement mais ce serait passer que 20
ans depuis cette première histoire c'est
le même parapluie c'est un nouveau
visage ces deux nouvelles chansons
le retour de mary poppins
[Musique]
mary poppins quel bonheur de vous revoir
en effet je vous le confirme alors c'est
réussi 3 étoiles et demie pour ce film
donc qui est moins une suite qu'une
variation sur le premier film
rappelez-vous même pas pu me venaient à
la rescousse de la famille banks
maintenant elle vient à la rescousse des
enfants de la famille benz mais le
poppers avait un grand ami le ramoneur
jovial cette fois c'est un allumeur de
réverbères de très bonne humeur et
chantait on chantait super cali fragile
du machin sexy lumineau magie thérapie
donc vous voyez on n'est toujours pas
très loin de l'umno magie fantastique
très loin de l'original en fait c'est
une bien sûr du déjà vu mais ça
fonctionne parce que il ya des choses
qu'on aime
l'animation par exemple qu'il revienne
et que van dyke qui revient à 93,1 oui
bon pied bon oeil
on s'était beaucoup cité ce mélange de
l'animation et des duvets du et des
personnages réels dans le premier qui
étaient intéressés absolument il ya
l'époque c'était révolutionnaire bien
sûr maintenant on a vu quelque chose qui
ressemble à ça emily blunt n'a rien à
envier à julian jaws si vous dire avant
qu'elle est vraiment parfaite
et puis les deux raisons d'aller voir ce
film sont toutes simples
la première c'est le merveilleux et la
deuxième c'est la bienveillance et voilà
deux choses à la période des fêtes qu'on
n'aura jamais trop je vous souhaite
beaucoup de merveilleux beaucoup de
bienveillance
un film familial donc le retour de mary
poppins pour dire que c'est bien 10 la
bienveillance on n'a pas ça fait défaut
parfois l'on change de registre
incomplet roma brda paris comme
phénomène la semaine dernière parce que
sur netflix et dans quelques salles
seulement socialement sur netflix
c'est le lion d'or du festival de venise
le film le plus personnel d'alfonso
cajon le réalisateur de gravité
notamment
il revient sur le quartier de son
enfance à mexico ce quartier se nommait
roma
[Musique]
est ce que vous vous aussi vous dites
est un chef-d'oeuvre 4 étoiles et demie
hall c'est un film exceptionnel le noir
et blanc est inoubliable
c'est vraiment merveilleux les cadrages
sont parfaits et l'environnement sonore
aussi et c'est un film qui me sur notre
intelligence
on avance lentement dans cette histoire
je pourrais vous dire qu'il ya un
incendie tremblement terre une émeute
c'est vrai mais ce qui a surtout c'est
une femme elle se nomme clé où c'est la
domestique de la famille couronne
puisqu'il raconte son histoire
cette femme du coeur on a une affection
incroyable pour elle en avance dans son
histoire on veut la prendre dans leurs
bras et en fait ce film c'est une
confidence puisque c'est une confidence
c'est quelque chose qu'on vous murmure à
l'oreille
quelque chose de précieux quelque chose
de rare quelque chose que vous ramenez
avec vous en vous disant quand même
c'est un moment exceptionnel c'est
exactement ce que vous vivrez envoyant
quoi ron qui est présenté sur certains
écrans dans la région de montréal on a
de la chance
néanmoins sur netflix bien sûr depuis
quelques jours mais justement parlez moi
tienne seconde car même de le fait de le
voir à la télé sur netflix vous voulez
vous avez vu les deux j'avais vu sur
grand écran par la plupart des gens le
verront oui à la télé et c'est pour ça
que je vous dis ça commence lentement
donc c'est pas un film qui a le rythme
de ce que l'on voit à la télévision
parce qu'il faut effectivement et dans
ces dispositions là pour faire son
lavage pour répondre à son message
accepter le rythme du film vous serez
payé de retour alors que l'inter
derrière plaint d'ailleurs très bien ça
c'est à voir
et c'est noté tout tout tout autre chose
parce que c'est une satire politique et
en fait c'est le portrait du
vice-président américain dick cheney qui
était pas un second violon vis
vice-présidence derrière plus grands
titres symboliques sont moins
main mais on peut peut-être s'entendre
pour en revoir la définition
je pourrais m'occuper des dossiers moins
attrayant tu t'es inter comme superviser
la bureaucratie l'armée
hemmer ch
la politique étrangère bonne idée
j'adore ce trois étoiles et demie
patrice mars qu'il avait pris tout le
pouvoir
bush vous allez adorer ce film je pense
et le mauvais sens fait se réfère autant
à sa fonction qu'à sa personnalité est
en fait si vous voulez voir un
documentaire sur dick cheney passez
votre chemin et vous serez profondément
déçu parce que ce film est une forme de
démonstration de démonstration assez
cruel il ya de la distorsion des faits
mais parce qu'on veut dire quelque chose
et c'est une valse un jeu et que le
spectateur si vous avez vu de big shot
il quitte donc le film précédent d
amener qui nous il parlait de la
situation économique en 2008 et
d'effondrement mais c'est le même type
de président et aspirent oui et on
niveau rendement et là ça fonctionne il
faut dire un kristen bell est
méconnaissable
on croirait déchaînés et sam rockwell
s'est littéralement transformé en george
w bush
bref pour quelqu'un comme moi comme vous
c'est purement jouissif fleurs du bonbon
comédie-française l'homme pressé encore
là un homme de pouvoir
mais un homme qui on connaît une chute
terrible qui sera finalement sa planche
de salut parce qu'il avait perdu sa vie
de vue un homme pressé bonjour monsieur
à flers tu dis jamais merci pas pire
mais ya deux erreurs
pour les autres vous allez vous reposer
j'aurais voté quand je serai mort
monsieur et au monsieur je rêve souvent
mon père a fait un avc écoutez c'est pas
forcément d'ordre alors trois étoiles
pour ce film inspiré de la vie du patron
de peugeot citroën l'ancien patron
peugeot citroën qui a été victime d'un
avc il a perdu le contrôle du langage
donc le contrôle de tout parce qu'ils
savaient plus s'exprimer
est ce que vous pouvez imaginer un
meilleur acteur pour jouer ça que
fabrice luchini le maître des mots il a
un plaisir fou là-dedans il est très
sobre
vous irez au film voir le film pour voir
patrice fabrice luchini mais vous en
sortirez après avoir vu les lacs et i
qui vous paraîtra c'est son
orthophoniste dans le film qui vous
paraîtra particulièrement émouvante
c'est la découverte pour bien des
spectateurs
bref c'est pas un grand film français
puisque film quelque chose à dire on
commence dans la finance et dans les
affaires et puis on avance vers
compostelle et pourquoi pas ici on est
dans l'esprit des fêtes
mais c'est très bien quatre bonnes
suggestions pire rafale oui rapidement
je vous propose trois films qui méritent
tous quatre étoiles une affaire de
famille la palme d'or du festival de
cannes
sybille street pouvait parler le film de
barry jenkins inspiré d'une oeuvre de
james baldwin extraordinaire et la
favorite de yorgos lanthimos le cinéaste
grec travail mettant en anglais c'est
son troisième film en anglais là aussi
remarquable trois films qui seront
présents aux oscars attendez vous à les
voir et les revoir dans les remises de
prix de fin d'année
michel remarquable chronique quand on
sait tous on a beaucoup de suggestions à
vous avez du travail on à la
bienveillance que l'on se souhaite la
bienveillance et le merveilleux c'est ce
que je souhaite pour la période des
fêtes
au revoir joyeux se faire voir